oh
y avait tout ce qu'il faut
guylaine tremblay pour la première fois
de votre carrière vous y allez avec un
spectacle autobiographique
je pense que la base de votre nouveau
spectacle autobiographique se dire yvon
deschamps m'a fait prendre conscience de
bien des choses ah oui professeurs comme
à fait ça ouais la professeure les
souvent quand on est en phase faut que
je sois très très honnête avec vous par
exemple j'avais un gros kick dessus
quand j'avais huit ou neuf ans au
souvent tout commence par un week-end
faut bien se dire ah ne va pas ce que
moi je le trouvais beau jeu pas comme un
show pas pourquoi
faut toujours que je me trouve là
j'ai trouvé que ce petit oeil la
pétillante intelligence mocquard mais en
même temps il y avait une douceur déjà
que moi châtel danse regarde où je
trouvais beau - j'aimerais donner
chouette joie de football puis vont
décharger les prix vont déjà n'importe
quand j'étais attiré par
par 7 ce qui dégage donc c'est se
dégustait les beaux yvon deschamps comme
toutes les petites rues on le sait quand
on est un petit clic sur quelqu'un qui
après 11 ans 12 ans je me mets à écouter
ses textes et à l'école sommes de plus
en plus j'ai toujours le clic dessus
j'aurai toujours l'équipe de suisse du
mondial donc c'est plus serré les ya 86
ans l'équipe de suisse pas grave deux
jours non
je le dis très bon
deux démos s'appelle dabbagh
mais quand même on sent que des mollahs
comme lésions qu'assad hommes d'yvon
deschamps nous ont vraiment marqué entre
autres sur notre vision de la justice
sur sur le monde qui vous entoure de
quelle façon et moi je viens d'un milieu
ouvrier dans des gens partant je
m'identifiais beaucoup yvon deschamps
qui vient d'un milieu populaire et
ouvrier comme moi donc d'entendre les
unions que ça donne c'est ce que je
regardais mon père mes oncles mes
cousins je me disais très très naïvement
ce que je devais avoir 10 ou 11 heures
quels sont ils j'espère que mon père
c'est pour faire ça par son patron puis
si oui faut se battre faux pas s'il faut
pas que ça arrive alors très vite tu ça
a réveillé ma capacité à m'indigner si
c'est pour vous voulez quand les
injustices et puis
je suis devenu comme une adolescente
très militante - ouais j'ai fatigante
vous avez passé votre adolescence mais
vous avez fait des études au
conservatoire d'art dramatique de québec
qui emmenait sa 83e des images on voit
où sommet de la jeunesse où vous faites
la comique oui mais oui mais oui
justement cacher
et ça me va passer j'avais oublié de te
dire la cites à propos des journalistes
ricochet apprendre à le connaître ben
oui parce que c'était plus et c'était
plus facile pour moi moi je sais pas
répond que quelqu'un de très pudique
mais qu'as tu fait à comique que tu
mènes férus les lunettes que tu composes
on engage ce qui disparaît toi petit
plus alarmant données et profite à lyon
de sabots fallait la perruque lunettes
glen non on veut te voir toi mais quand
même ça vous ce suivi parce que le
carreau dans la petite vie vous avez
joué dans ding dong le film où c'est le
comique est resté tout mais j'adore ça
j'adore c'est ce que moi je mets j'adore
changer de toute façon je pourrais pas
faire juste du drame ont juste la
comédie ce métier l'homme me donne une
liberté de me promener la dame et le
rire c'est quand même assez formidable
comment ça se fait que rod le doit de
prendre le champion des juges avec moi
de l'avoir à coutances apprend que jack
straw concurrence
rien répond deschamps in the éduqué par
le rire d'abord et avant tout écouter
mais c'est ici il ya là des groseilles à
la déplacer gala des fermes ayala
a chanté des chansons d'yvon deschamps
dont les fesses vous n'êtes pas
chanteuse et non pas du tout alors
comment vous y prenez pour infraction
mais c'est une bonne question parce que
tu es souvent les gens monde masculin
n'est pas une chanteuse à le chanter je
chantais dans belle savons le fantôme
sommet spawn chanteuse met à l'enjeu
suis rendu ces puces qui est important
vraiment pas si j'avais fait ce
spectacle à 35 ap j'aurais pas fait
problème j'aurais dit mais non je prends
une chanteuse je crois car perso je
performerai pas bien rendu où je suis
dans ma ville à la performance
ne plus l'importance qu'elle avait est à
dire que c'est je reviens est ce que je
vous disais c'est le partage moi je suis
pas une chanteuse
j'en serai jamais une mais j'ai envie
d'interpréter ses chansons et de les
partager parce qu'elles sont vains et
qu'elle me touche un film bon c'est sûr
que tu voulais chanter du nu petit peu
mais ils vont deschamps jamais été
reconnu pour pour remplacer caruso a
maintenant dix ans elle vit
et on se foutait complètement passée son
car
c'est son cas alors moi c'est mon coeur
que je veux livrer aussi les chansons
sont si belles
sont si belles dulin tremble merci merci
beaucoup je serai pas comme un chapeau
pourquoi
faut toujours que je me retrouve là
[Musique]